oh you told me Scott and carried by wind
away distance
let us remember that wholeness tears
unnatural stain come together bones and
lace devastated by bells lost and
[Music]
forgotten twice once more and relish its
blade
[Music]
[Music]
with the students on hello and welcome
to space for action rebuilding a
sustainable world
for the next hour so we will hear for
musicians and climate activists across
disciplines and institutions who all
believe that we can build a post
pandemic future that is sustainable and
equitable for all climate change is an
issue that affects everyone and we
encourage you to take this time to
reflect and listen with a posture of
imagination hope and readiness for
action at the end of this event there
will be time for group discussion and
follow-up we hope to connect and inspire
action in every field and community
represented here today we are all part
of the fight to save our ecosystem
before we move on in our program I'd
like to take a moment to acknowledge
that most if not all of us on this call
are presently residing on stolen land
from native tribes who are the original
stewards of what we now call North
America in the Greater Boston area re
reside on the land stolen from the
Wampanoag and massachusett tribes let us
take a moment to acknowledge how we
continue to marginalize kill Agnew and
ignore the crucial wisdom of indigenous
peoples in the US and how they were
forced to endure multiple pandemics when
America's first colonizers landed on the
soil we have a link in the chat if you'd
like to check out where you are in the
US and what native peoples indigenous
tribes are the original stewards of that
land we
opened our program with an original
composition by Ricky Richardson jazz
artist and educator in the Boston area
Thank You Ricky next we have our first
speaker leader in climate activism and
social justice movements a fellow of
Boston's green justice coalition and
founding pastor of new roots AME Church
in Dorchester
Reverend Maruyama white Hammond hello
it's good to be with you this evening
wherever you are I think many of us are
in the Boston area but there are also
folks from many different places and in
this virtual moment we miss being in at
each other's physical presence but we
are also leaning into the opportunity to
connect even more across the boundaries
that usually divide us so in my
tradition I want to begin by saying good
evening and I know that I can't hear you
all saying good evening back the kahlan
response doesn't quite work on zoom'
like it does in search but good evening
I say to you recognizing that for some
of us this actually is a statement of
faith to say that it is a good evening
means to imagine and let go of some of
the anxiety that we feel to say it is a
good evening
means that for this moment we take a
little respite from the suffering that
we see around us in so many places as
we're in this koban moment I think one
of the hardest parts is being separated
from people that we love not being able
to be in their physical presence I'm a
hugger and even when I go to my parents
house to take in their groceries my mom
says she loves me but she also walks
behind me with alcohol wipes wiping
everything down they go I haven't been
able to give her a hug and more than six
weeks now I worry sometimes about our
children growing up in an age where we
think that showing love means not being
in proximity and the challenge that that
means for us in this moment
I think particularly about one of my
family member is that I miss my
goddaughter seraya for many of our my
family members I've been able to be on
the phone with them and I have with her
too but as a five year old her attention
span for phone checks is limited so I
see her and then she bounces off
somewhere else runs back in tells me
something and then bounces off somewhere
else
I love xariah she is strong she's
confident she's intrepid and even as we
speak I have been making cookies for her
that are cooling down right now she's
allergic to eggs so she's shortbread
cookies no eggs no milk but I think a
lot about suraíh abhi cuz when she's
here and I like I said she's confident
and intrepid which means that she also
finds her way getting into trouble
sometimes and often when we have a
moment I have to put her on the timeout
step as she gets taller her time out
step back went from being step one to
step two and I'm sure that any day now
she'll be on time out on step three on
the back on the front steps I think that
the reality is when I send her to
timeout
it is my hope although sometimes it's
not always the case that she will sit on
the step and reflect on the thing that
has led her there sometimes I think
she's reflecting on how she can beat me
by a hole waiting on the step and still
getting off and still holding whatever
opinioned is that she already had before
or whatever it is that she did but I it
is my hope as a godmother that putting
her on that timeout step he's a moment
of reflection a moment for her to think
about how she needs to be different how
she can approach that space differently
the truth is that right now we as
humanity have been put on a timeout step
we've had a moment we have a moment to
sit and to reflect on who we've been and
who we want to be now we could do what
sometimes my goddaughter does which is
your timeout time comes up and you jump
up and try to ignore whatever put you
there in the first place or go back to
doing the exact same thing you were
doing before or as she matures I see her
when we have our post timeout step
reflection time not just running away
from me but being able to engage more
deeply in a conversation about what
needs to shift and change the purpose of
tonight is for us to begin a
conversation maybe for some of us is the
extension of a conversation we've
already started
about what is required of us as humanity
in this moment where we've been put on
timeout this timeout moment has given
more respite to the planet that she's
had in a long time we are not driving or
flying or pumping out emissions at the
same rate that we usually do
we are not dumping we are not throwing
away at the same rate that we usually do
and for the first time in my
neighborhood I can hear the birds taking
over in the morning
filling the trees laying their eggs and
embracing the spring probably is the
best time that they've ever experienced
but we won't be on timeout forever the
moment will come when we get off of this
and we are asked to think about whether
or not we are people who are ready to
shift to be different to emerge from
this changed for some of us on this call
we've been very engaged around climate
change issues maybe the future that
we're looking at has gotten to us maybe
we experience deep levels of climate
grief as we consider the future that
we're facing
maybe this grief has even made us
paralyzed unclear about how we can do or
affect anything
my invitation to you today
is that maybe by yourself we you cannot
shift things but together we have an
opportunity to change the course of
human history for the first time in my
lifetime
people are paused people are asking hard
questions about who we are and who we
want to be many of us for the first time
are seeing our trash collectors seeing
our janitors
seeing our supermarket workers people
who have always been doing important
work but far too often and completely
unappreciated and overlooked
for the first time we are talking in
some instances about health inequities
that are leading to some people
literally dying too soon
and so we have an opportunity to take
this moment this time out moment and ask
who do we want to be on the other side
of this you're gonna hear from lots of
great people tonight who will frame for
you the specifics of the science of
climate political action and artistic
expression all amazing ways that we can
act and then you'll have an opportunity
to be in conversation with folks
because the question for tonight is not
just to have a good time not just to be
inspired but to discern what is each of
ours to do using our collective gifts
and talents what is possible that maybe
wasn't before how does this become the
moment in which humanity begins to trace
a shift a turn a new way of being that
reflects the urgency of this moment that
takes care of those most vulnerable
this is the story that I hope to tell
Sariah
but when she's 15 and 25
and living in a world where we take
inequity much more seriously where we
have turned the corner on climate
emissions it is my hope and my prayer
that I tell her
it all started with us taking seriously
a moment of time out to shift to change
to be the people you're called to be
Thank You Reverend Maruyama we will now
hear from ed mark alone into teacher
eeeh
ed Mar is a saxophonist pianist and
composer from Puerto Rico who is
currently on the faculty of the Berklee
College of Music
Tootie is a singer songwriter actor and
voice over artist and they have both
performed worldwide today they will be
performing somewhere over the rainbow so
it is my pleasure to introduce my dear
friends to T and Ed Marr
[Music]
Oh
there's
that I've heard of
[Music]
that you dare to dream really do come
too
[Music]
some day young star and wake up where
the clouds are far behind
[Music]
he talks that way
[Music]
the ring if
the
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
incredible thank you and by the way
everybody if you want to show your
appreciation for the performers and the
speakers feel free to use the zoom clap
hands or a thumbs up feature that thumbs
up means a lot to us so thank you again
that was Ed mark alone and two teacher
yon it is now my honor to introduce a
person who has been on the front lines
of the fight for environmental justice
since we began to understand the effects
of human activity on the climate in the
1980's award-winning author journalist
and environmentalist Bill McKibben is a
founder of 350.org and is currently the
Schumann distinguished scholar in
environmental studies at Middlebury
College with his writing bill has a
unique ability to deliver the hard
truths we need to hear while still
inspiring hope all the while bringing us
deeper into our respect and all for the
natural world we are very honored to
have them here with us tonight
please let us virtually welcome Bill
McKibben well thank you very much what a
pleasure to be with you all
Reverend white Hammond I've been missing
church immensely and well I'll look
forward to getting to Boston so I can
sit in a Pew it new roots a me but that
was really good tonight to be in your
church and representative Presley thank
you for helping remind us all that we
don't need to be cynical about all our
political leaders and esperanza spalding
what can one say my favorite bassist
since James Jamerson anyway and and you
know what a pleasure to to hear all
these other voices that I didn't know
before tonight and to be reminded how
much we need each other's voices one of
the things that happens in these weeks
is a kind of silence falls across our
lives and yes it's a moment for
reflection but man the gregarious part
of our beings is dying to get back out
of detention known and able to
and so thanks so much to the people who
put this together tonight let me offer
just a few reflections as we're in this
time of pandemic about the larger crisis
that goes on all the time this climate
crisis that will dominate our century
first thing we're reminded in these
weeks of the most basic fact of all that
reality is real that physical reality
can't be wished away or compromised away
or negotiated away it doesn't matter if
you get up at a lectern and you know
tell the coronavirus that it's a hoax it
doesn't care I've spent the last thirty
years trying to convince people that
physics and chemistry matter that they
can't be spun or talked away in in just
the same way the coded microbe is
reminding us now that it sets the limits
and we need to listen if it says stand
six feet apart and six feet apart
we need to stand and that message going
forward has got to be you know we live
in a world where we stare into screens
all the time and where it's easy to
forget what reality is about and we're
getting a reminder second a key feature
of that reminder is that timing is
everything you know the u.s. and South
Korea had their first case of
coronavirus on the same day in January
the South Koreans went to work they
disrupted their lives no big gathering
started testing everyone they're now
looking at this in the rearview mirror
instead of having it come crashing
through the windshield like we did
because we delayed we didn't flatten the
curve in time any more than we worked to
flatten the carbon curve 30 years ago
when scientists first issued their
warning that means that the action we
have to take now is both disruptive and
will inevitably be accompanied by lots
of loss and pain even in the best of
circumstances but it doesn't change the
basic reality that speed
is everything that we have to go and a
different pace than we've been going in
dealing with the climate crisis um there
are no silver linings to something like
a pandemic but out of this kind of
trauma we best learn something and that
something probably should be that speed
is speed is essential the third and
final thing is that social solidarity is
absolutely at the root of what we have
to do now um you know America has lived
for the last 40 years under the
political spell of Ronald Reagan on the
idea that markets solve everything that
we should each just pursue our own
self-interest that as mr. Reagan said
the nine scariest words and the English
language are I'm from the government and
I'm here to help you but we know now
that that's not the case the scariest
words in the English language are we've
run out of ventilators or the hillside
on your behind your house is on fire
okay and those kind of problems we can
only solve when we work together and
when I say together I mean not just
those of us in America this is a global
these are both global problems
we're all dealing with such trauma that
it's hard to remember places in the
world that are under extraordinary
imagine trying to lock down in India
with a billion people and being told to
wash your hands in places with no
running water but then also imagine that
you're in Delhi and you're getting the
first lung full of clean air that you've
ever breathed in your life we need to
take the things that we can see around
us that clean air that clean water and
we need to cherish that too we need to
not go back just to normal we know we
need not to just set up the pins and the
bowling alley again this is a moment
when we're being offered as Reverend
white Hammond's
I kind of reset an opportunity to think
differently about what the future might
look like and and I hope and trust that
we will take that opportunity but only
if we all work together to push it in
the most powerful ways so so many thanks
to everybody here tonight
[Music]
society is gasping for air life as we
know it no longer acknowledges us we are
turning over the soil
this jungle of ideological innovation
once teeming with life is now exposing
its decay vines intent on suffocating
are choking on themselves it is time to
cut back on what has become invasive
mother
earth will not wait around
baris or mother too abstract for you
[Music]
life-giver
supplier of all that we take credit for
get this machine that we have so
carefully constructed and carelessly
empowered won't stop for us
[Music]
but that which sustained
nature in her resilience splendor she
won't stop for us either will be walk
alongside her or bulldoze a head body
and my
she's not some pledging to be conquered
coddled colonized civilized
[Music]
she is
force that brings you to your new she is
also beauty laughter wonder that will
bring you to your knees the present is
bringing us to our knees
[Applause]
what will we grow now in this turning
soil
riped with the remains of mishandled
provision what will we learn in the wake
of our blunders grief clenched like a
fist in our throat longs for release
into a rallying cry
[Music]
but we leave
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
our shadows always remind us lovely
actors of present-day arts become
shadows always reminds me
what believe me hi
let every my knives right we leave
behind what we leave
[Music]
hmm thank you so much Peter teondra for
that reminder this moment of what you're
called to and you make it sound really
good so it's a great beautiful
combination so I'd want to just take
this moment really quickly to introduce
a woman who really doesn't need much of
an introduction I have known her since
2009 when she became the first black
woman woman of color to serve on the
Boston City Council and then after that
moment she worked hard to make that City
Council open and now we have a C Council
that is predominantly women and for the
first time is has many people of color
and so you know I've watched her for
years
in 2016 she was named by Grist as one of
the 50 fixers and in 2018 she ran in a
race that everybody told her she
couldn't do like she just should wait
her turn and she pushed through and she
won and is now representing the
Massachusetts 7th congressional district
Ayana Presley is a champion she speaks
her mind she is powerful and she speaks
with conviction but again what I love
the most about her is that when she
opens doors she makes sure that other
people are able to walk through them she
makes sure the folks whose voices have
not been heard our centered are heard
and not just that she's a masterful
policy maker she's drawn a little ire
from those people who don't like strong
bold smart women and I am so thankful to
call her not just my congresswoman but
also my friend
that was so generous my sister I'm gonna
say a few words about you in a moment
Reverend Mari but first I just you know
I was reminded as I was listening to
these incredibly talented moving artists
who are lending their skills to this
moment I've always believed every single
person has a role to play in the
movement
some people will recite a poem some
people will spin a rap some people will
sing a song some people will use the pen
use the paintbrush but a microphone we
all have a role to play in the movement
and recently I was in Alabama
shortly before things got to where they
are now with this pandemic to recreate
the Bloody Sunday March and walk the
Edmund Pettus Bridge and they were
talking about the role of song in the
movement and one of the elders said that
you make age the singer but never the
song and I was reminded of that as I was
listening to these very moving and
uplifting artists today so thank you you
know in my faith tradition we say is it
sin to have a gift and to not share with
the world
so I want to thank you for sharing your
gift for lending for lending those so
generously to this moment I'm honored to
be invited to this virtual table today
at this critical juncture and crossroads
for our nation for our world I want to
thank my sister Reverend Mario when I
first found out about this event I said
if Mari is a part of it I know there's
going to be music and so I'm so grateful
that there was today and when I think of
Mari I'm always reminded of the African
proverb that said when you pray move
your feet and mari is always praying and
she is always moving her feet organizing
mobilizing coalition building every
single day she is indefatigable in the
pursuit of justice before I get into any
more formal remarks I do want to pause
and just take a moment to say that I
hope that you and and those that you
love most are
a safe and healthy physically
emotionally and spiritually this is a
difficult time for so many reasons but I
want you to know that you are not alone
and we will get through this I'm
grateful that thanks to technology
although we are physically distant
saying that we can make sure that we are
not socially isolating and then we can
continue to come together in community
and be connected this is especially
important as we continue to build and
grow and to inform joy Marv you may
recall after my Washington DC
swearing-in I came to Roxbury - Roxbury
Kennedy college for a community
ceremonial swearing-in and I had
everyone take a pledge an oath with me
and I want to numerate every tenant of
that pledge that I had community take
with me and I did that because we do
this work symbiotically and this is not
what I do alone and even if I could I
wouldn't want to
I love the chosen family that we find
and we build along the way based on
aligned values and vision like all of
you that are part of this virtual table
this evening but one of the tenants of
that place that I will inform joy and we
know that joy is a necessary act of
resistance and so I thank all of you for
the role that you have played in shaking
the table in inviting others to this
table and for informing joy this
conversation is timely not only because
this week we acknowledge the 50th
anniversary of Earth Day but of course
because of the intersectionality of our
fight to address this global pandemic
and its ties to our fight against
climate change and environmental
injustice I mean really that's it's at
the center of all of this we are seeing
every inequity every injustice that
everyone that's a part of this and
beyond that we have been an organizing
and activist community with have been
working to dismantle and to mitigate and
to address all of these inequities and
disparities become exposed and further
entrenched in this movement in this
moment whether you're talking about food
insecurity or housing insecurity or
water and security people you know
there are those no one here but those
that think that that's just something
that happens other places but but no and
water and security and so this pandemic
is exposing these deep systemic
inequities and equities that long good
present but what this moment is also
exposing to Reverend Murray's point
earlier is an opportunity an opportunity
to rebuild in a more equitable way and
I've heard so many people saying
recently they can't wait until we return
to normal I don't want to I know you
don't want to return to her normal where
black and brown communities
disproportionately suffer these health
disparities that could be combated with
equal access to health care and by our
acknowledging and addressing and
dismantling actively structural racism
and the collateral consequences of that
structural racism yielding food deserts
transportation deserts and other
disproportionate burdens of
environmental injustice --is returning
to normal is not an option not after
this Kovach 19 respiratory illness has
pulled back the last of the veils on
environmental injustice we cannot return
to normal when minority and low-income
communities and evenly bare the brunt of
the health consequences associated with
air pollution as black and brown
families are exposed to 60% more air
pollution than they caused kovat 19 is
killing those with asthma and other
respiratory problems caused by living in
highly polluted areas being poor should
not be a pre-existing condition and no
one in this nation should have to be
wealthy in order to be healthy and the
cost of asthma medication to treat
pollution caused illness is skyrocketing
now just let me just share a story with
you just last weekend I went to get my
replacement in handler the generic brand
that I used was sold out and with a
waitlist and I was told that my option
was an inhaler that cost $175
while my usual copay is 10 dollars even
breathing I mean everything is political
including just breathing 50 years since
the establishment of the EPA we have a
president or as I like to call him the
occupant he's simply occupying space who
continues to invest in the failing
fossil fuel industry and who was rolling
back air and water pollution standards
deregulated fracking sites plants and
factories built without consent and our
poorest neighborhoods we stand in the
footsteps of great resistors and table
shakers and we will continue to fight
for progress in a real and tangible way
this pandemic shows the
interconnectedness of these battles that
our fight for a just economy health care
system and environment are all tied
yesterday I was in DC voting on an
additional funding to address this
pandemic the legislation that I voted to
pass included my proposal mandating that
the CDC release data on race and
ethnicity when it comes to Coba 19 I
fought for the inclusion of this data
because history shows us black and brown
communities do bear the brunt of all our
public health challenges in large part
due to the impacts of pollution and
global warming we can now get that data
that confirms the disparities and we can
save lives with that data it's not
collection for the sake of collection
it's so that the resources can follow
where the data is going with this
information we can get ahead of this we
must continue to do more I hope you will
join me and continue the fight for
Medicare for all and to address racism
in our health care system for affordable
asbestos and lead free housing for all
and better food access and of course for
a green new deal to save our most
vulnerable populations already suffering
the impacts of climate change we have an
opportunity here an obligation to build
a more equitable future and I'm so
grateful for all of you front liners new
community builders to be your sister in
solidarity and actual izing that vision
and for those that don't get it I have
great confidence and your powers of
persuasion and influence and
storytelling to bring others along thank
you
[Music]
Blake thank you so much for gracing us
with your deeply thoughtful music Ram
Blake is athirst dream pioneer devoted
educator deeply involved in protest
music and a devoted connoisseur of film
noir a true bright shining light in the
world of music and beyond much much
gratitude to to Representative Presley
for her amazing remarks and now speaking
of pioneers our next special guest is a
true force of nature that since the
inception of her career has been
propelling her feel forward with mighty
speed and depth while inspiring many to
explore their highest potential as
artists and human beings please help me
virtually welcome Grammy award-winning
artists and big advocate for a climate
and natural environment and paraphrasing
from Reverend Marianas words I get to
call her my dear friend my sister
Esperanza Spalding
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you may not be true searching an engine
for the ghost of heart yogurts your skin
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
eating
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you so much
Esperanza for giving such a beautiful
voice to the thoughts that roll through
so many of our minds but when they come
out of your mouth they sound angelic so
thank you I hope that the voices you
have heard have spoken to to your spirit
that the art and the music that we've
experienced has gotten and touched you
in a place that maybe nothing else can
and each speaker and artist has really
issued a call to action not simply to
enjoy this moment but to lean into this
moment to figure out what we are called
to and I know on this call I've seen
some of
there are artists there are activists
there are folks who work on
environmental issues and many other
issues and so I want to before we go
into our break up rooms at a time for us
to reflect for us to think about those
things that we are called to do in
response to what we've heard this
evening I want to give each speaker just
a moment to share if there's one last
couple of sentences that you want to
issue as a call to action or reflection
as people head into their breakout rooms
and so I will queue first to Presley
then to Bill McKibben and finally to
Esperanza just there is there a two
sentences a word that you want to
capture for for us to be thinking about
you guys hear me read it okay I just I
think everything has already been said
and I know you need to get to these
breakouts so what I just wanted to say
in this moment what I'm feeling is just
immense gratitude and just what a gift
it was to be in community with all of
you and to your point Murray as
beautiful as that is that we have to to
lean into what will be required of all
of us beyond this moment and so revisit
this beyond today because it will
fortify us in those most challenging
moments as we seek to build
intentionally a more just an equitable
world and personally and outwardly
informing joy along the way I do have
one quick action though which is like my
new thing if everyone will put your
hands up to the corners of your screen
we can all hold hands just touch the
edges nice thank you
blessings
he'll take it away what do you want us
to be thinking of look I'm so just
overwhelmed by the music and the words
tonight I just you know I think we need
this so much right now I think if we had
if there was some kind of um machine
that could record ambience sadness in
the atmosphere I think our country right
now would be you know the needle would
be pinned in the red so many people
morning so many people terrified for
those around them that are ailing so
many people dealing with the job they're
lost or they're gonna lose sometime soon
and that we're I think the phrase that
has to it just has to be in our minds
and hearts all the time is we're all in
this together if we can't figure out a
way out of this together then we will
not figure out a way out so that's what
we got to do thank you and Esperanza
what's on your mind what's in your heart
so much gratitude thank you for all of
you who organized this and thank you for
everyone who made time to share present
and I just invite anyone with the gift
of music to recognize the power that we
have right now to contribute to the
healing and the bullying through this
moment and on the other side if we
weren't sure before that music is a
basic human necessity I'm sure on the
other side of this will be even more
reminded of how potent music is in our
lives and hopefully we can all show up
as advocates to make sure that these
artists are well fed we'll house and
have all the things they need to be able
to serve our community so thank you
thank you
and to Grand Lake do you have a final
word before we break what's your
reflection in this moment oh wait we
can't hear you seldom
[Music]
all right now we can thank you so you
have your charge everybody we've got to
figure out this road together and so now
you have the opportunity we'll be
breaking up into breakout rooms for you
to begin this conversation with with the
folks in your room each room will have a
facilitator that will help
here our heart be like the drum loud and
Shore feel the rush through our veins
cool and pure now the oneness of our
spirit shall endure say oh yeah oh yeah
come we offer this deep gratitude to
each of you in bringing our collective
spirits together in this moment and
there will be so many more opportunities
for us to go deep with each other asking
the question who do we choose to be and
so the blessing for this evening is that
we choose to be as bold and as beautiful
as imaginative and as loving as creator
has called us to be that we emerge from
this moment the people that we've always
hoped to be and that because of that the
world is forever transformed thank you
so much river Maruyama
all the gay speakers congresswoman diana
oppress lee bill mckibben esperanza
spalding ram Blake Rikki Richardson
Peter Godard and tiandra Rae - - Julian
and I member : thank you from space for
action and now Peter is gonna continue
in some laws that may happen yes and
thank you again to the people who
brought this to you especially Fred
Harris who's been a visionary throughout
this entire process and has been a key a
pivotal member of the space for action
team cam eated all these Susan Wilson
cuoco dog Leo clean Ashlyn jure Isobel
doc Leo for making this happen on the
production side of things
shout out to Julie Newman and Susie and
Nicole at the MIT office of
sustainability Heidi Erickson and MIT
Center for Arts sciences technology Erin
Hartley and Dec tour for helping out
with ran as well as the Lisa Cunningham
and DJ who helped out being moderators
and I'll kick it off to teondra who will
tell you how to stay connected once this
event ends great so thank you all for
sharing the space with us we hope that
going forward you you feel empowered to
fight climate change along with
everybody else here spaces fraction will
continue to host events and
conversations to encourage inter
disciplinary action and cooperation if
you'd like to be involved or stay
updated please check out our Facebook
group where we will continue the
conversation via subgroups and resource
sharing so I can throw that in in the
chat in a second we will also be sending
a follow-up email to all participants so
that you can all stay involved and we'll
send some resources we'll send a link to
the Facebook and yeah that's all that we
have thank you so much everyone for
being a part of this for joining we have
people from all over the country and it
was super excited I love the breakout
sessions and everything so
we'll be we'll be chatting with you soon
yes thank you everybody q thank you may
be loose may be exclusion oh can we can
open up everyone everybody can have a
mass vibration of everybody there waves
happening